i'm coming with sally babes we're
continuing babe fest 2021
exactly babe so true chrissy this is so
much fun hanging out in the hotel room
with you anyway babe fest is continuing
so get your tickets we got friday
october 29th in durham north carolina
that has been on sale that is going to
sell out you get those tickets right
away sunday december 26 will be in grand
prairie texas aka close to dallas monday
the 27th of december we are in san
antonio texas
the stars at night are big and bright
deep in the heart
continue with texas tuesday december
28th we will be in sugarland texas which
is near houston wednesday december 29th
st louis missouri thursday december 30th
in columbus ohio and new year's eve 2021
into 2022 join us friday december 31st
in cincinnati
january 1st i won't have a home he's a
pig don't see him
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey
[Music]
yo
hey chris inside there's some adam
babies keep my tip flowing with my
vision with my grandma man better keep
that gun hey chris and saw y'all so
dummy i'll be willing keep a wag one
stirring at the sun i'll be sun gazing
and we'll be putting up like we super
saiyan
there's some island baby y'all already
know hey shout out chris d and sal
appreciate it you gotta hear from a
shout out from the island boys it's
official and keep dancing alone man yes
yep and pop bottom give me an island
give me a hey baby
give me an island boy
give me a hey baby boy
give me an island boy
hey babe what's up babe what's up baby
baby i just at this point people know
what island boy is right because i just
saw it for the first time well it's
actually nice to see someone who hasn't
heard of island boy yet because it's
literally taking over
when did you hear about this for the
first time
i would say four days ago oh sorry
something like that i mean i heard about
it it went i'm living
i think the tick tock might be at like a
billion views it's insane a billion it
might whatever it is because people
don't understand what they're looking at
well have we identified these kids no
i'm sorry no no babe do whatever you got
to do for yourself um um
we haven't identified them where are
they from
has anyone interviewed them florida we
know that they're from florida
do they have their own tick tock channel
or is this why soldier is their youtube
channel um but now everyone's just now
everyone's just kind of redoing the
island boy i mean everybody's talking
about the island boys they're trying to
get on the podcast the island boys are
going to be on bar stool today or oh my
god last week whatever so and these are
just two kids just two kids that they
won crate but this camp this is the
official music video it's only got 370
000 views no way well this is before
they went big this is from september
oh so so they put it out there and it
didn't pop until a couple of days ago
they were just like you open micros who
eventually eventually yeah directed by
at pete shot look at these kids jesus
let me pause that for one sec pimp
where do you think it went wrong for
them
at home
at home right at home i would say
i think what do you think came first the
teeth the tats or the hair
i think the taps probably came first
yeah i think so too because that hair
has to come dead last yes that hair
can't lead the pack
you can't walk out regular with that
hair no no no no no it's like what's
that crusty car see the clown
like it's like crusty clown
is it a form of dreadlocks i guess
are they from an island no allegedly
they're from florida i don't think i
think they're probably how what do they
have on instagram now 235k all right i'm
still beating them is the is this barely
is this an effect like is this them
speaking this way or is this their
normal speaking voice no i think that's
them putting on a dialect they're
claiming i think we might have a
hilarious baldwin situation on our hands
where they're now coming out and
claiming they're cuban but they probably
are just white kids okay that just are
have lost their minds y'all get real bro
man
stop playing to tap in and message him
to see what he about man love he shows
support man yeah
see i understood more of the island boys
song than that i don't think i
understood one word i understood the the
island boys song when they're literally
saying nothing i understood more oh yeah
can we watch that again let's play a
game yes where we try to translate what
they say got it okay okay
okay okay okay i think what they said
was that go in their dms and ask them if
pay them if they want to make a video
for you there's a package deal
but i don't know what the other guy said
and i also don't know what bro is i
don't know what it means but i think
from now at least for the rest of the
day to the podcast
yeah at the end when you say it when you
make any point it doesn't matter
because that's what it is now the island
boys i mean let's see okay now they're
in a way after they went to cvs and
bought a pool inflatable that's what
they did they i mean they had to blow
that up so and that takes long time so
like three hours of water they were
passing that back involved being like
because here's the thing is i understand
i understand the gut reaction is to say
i don't like these kids but i actually
do like these kids i think that these
kids are just they're literally have
stepped into a realm where they don't
care at all what you think of them i
would argue because i've been doing yoga
that they do a lot of yoga and they're
in a peaceful place they all said
are they 15
or are they making
minors 20 something
i mean i i hope they're 20 something i
don't think they they might be ageless
they're vampires they're reached seven
thousand years old what's this one what
they're doing problems for the love and
package deals hit us up in the dm
they're doing promos from iran can we
hit them up in the dm for the package
deals
oh let's get him to do a hey me promo
yeah let's get him through ebay promo
done okay we're going to get this oh
well we love you guys we love you guys
well i mean you think you think you're
going to hit us for like 10 g's what are
they going to hit us for well then we're
not we're not getting hit for 10 g's
let's be honest no one's paying no one's
paying them 10. somebody would give them
10. for 10 g's they have to do whatever
we want for a day yeah no i mean that's
even expensive play this clip i want to
see what they're doing i mean they're in
a pool right now on a rap wait wait did
they did they are they at a hotel or do
they own an in-ground pool i think this
is their home all right let's get this
going me and my twin brother we're doing
pac-man whoa
me and my twin brother this is twins
let's get this going me and my twin
brother we're doing packages we're doing
deals so hit us up is that's gonna be
the cash flow
wait a minute all right wait this is
wild this is what so okay so they're
twin brothers
i was gonna say you think they have a
third friend that even flaunts with that
style or they just walk at thanksgiving
is the right family regular interest or
two of them
i wonder what their other brother
imagine he looks nothing like that at
all he's just a regular kid with a
mushroom haircut
just comes in he's got a peanut allergy
this is a nice long clip here here we go
let's let's listen to this kid a little
bit i'm fascinated with him it's it's
kodiak red pimp we could play this on
the pod
do you think they copyright their music
what is this instagram
kodiak
red
[Music]
what a great belt
i've been thinking to myself who is on
it you've been trying to see what is the
thing he's holding
i got
[Music]
his goal is to make his mother proud
that's right i'm gonna do it till i make
my mother so proud my imagination oh
there's a tight family life they weren't
abandoned i would love for his i didn't
know if she put him down the river or
something i would i need to see his
parents i would love for his in the
middle of these clips his mother to just
run down and take the laptop like kevin
give me that yeah
we should be the only podcast to book
his parents yeah we should literally oh
my god so
do you think they live at home because
also they have gold teeth i think girls
can't be real jewels right
that's just all you can get anything on
amazon yeah yeah yeah okay so they they
seem like they're possibly from an
affluent family all right i finally got
some dates for you guys i will be at the
dania improv in fort lauderdale on
november 12th 13th and 14th i will be at
the west palm beach improv december 4th
and 5th i will be in boston in the
medford area at the chevalier theater on
december 10th and how about this first
time playing atlantic city solo i'm at
the borgata saturday december 11th come
on down for that
uh all tickets at
savilecanocomedy.com right now and more
dates to be announced soon i have not
been out i'm finally coming out at the
coven you better be there
they have a very beautiful home it's
obvious if that's their home i love the
top comment is is this satire
all right somebody ran somebody wrote
finally not for nothing but this hip-hop
is not hip-hop it's not he's just
speaking look how the amount of trash
cans they have commented two people just
coming
it's not there's not any real also
there's not any real any lyrical skill
wordplay
cadence
mark my words they will absolutely do a
song at the next mtv awards or so they
will open up with island boys island i
guarantee you this you are going to hear
from these kids for quite like bad baby
from dr phil 100 she calls that her own
thing look here's here's the thing maybe
i don't get it but that maybe i don't
have to get it
right maybe they're inventing their own
new thing that is just really
seems really easy
i'm honestly going to enjoy this for the
worst reasons right right it doesn't
matter they're entertaining us
you know what to be honest i mean we're
talking about them yeah but maybe it's
forest buyers shout out fubu i gotta
know we gotta know what they
we gotta know what their real names are
i guarantee you their real names are
like kevin and henry yeah there's no way
that they have thugged out real names i
know she didn't like my daddy
all right fly soldier
they just seen it when they see it like
it wash away but it's okay but it's okay
damn in on time when they seen you when
you ate keep it with nobody like you
flipping a rape kind of every time got
the phone people dead sitting with
nobody like you got it just correct did
someone needs to really stay at this
head i don't feel funny i be showing on
my face
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
let's take a look at one of their
produced music videos he looks like he
has an albatross tattooed in the middle
of his head imagine this is the this is
what the nazis became and hitler saw
this crystallized he was like gee this
is not true
is is he reading the words or does he
memorize all this this is a freestyle
we're watching oh he's freestyling no
it's not so pissed off you're from the
music industry you like music does he
have talent or is he trash
i i think he could sell tickets he could
sell tickets
between him and a takashi 6'9
uh we'll see if he opens fire at
barclays later they might have
they might have fallen from the same
tree is he i was going to say is this a
takashi 6 9 kind or kashi 69 actually
spit bars as as you and other white men
like comment on six nine great guy i
never met him these kids are probably
more positive i would say okay less
people want to murder them
now at this moment at this moment i'll
tell you though and i i'll bet it donuts
to dollars folks there you go i don't
think that look is going to age well i
i don't think it is no i suspect it
shall not and and it might even be like
within 10 years like imagine them at 70
years old right like i mean you know
what i mean and and the things are gray
do you think do you think let me ask you
this do you think the island boys will
be the number one costume on halloween
this year uh are they the number one
they are they're the number one right
you run into uh appropriation issues if
you really well they're white children
these are small white children we'll
find out they're just cute i mean look
at those cute little pockets what are
they on night vision
let's watch the music this is scarier
than watching ghosts inside my child
[Music]
they better not be white oh my goodness
they just dropped ends like three in a
sentence a quickie but i heard it
besides the n-word would you dance
around with your twin brother shirtless
no you know i don't have a twin so i
can't speak to it right because i would
dance around with you shirless no no
you're like my brother we might as well
be twins yeah
so he did also a gun i want to know is
this
influence is this all art influence from
artists like them before them or do they
live this life like he's pointing a gun
at the thing are they really is is it
this young if you have an in-ground pool
i don't think you're living that right
right you know what i mean you can't
it's one of the other if you live that
life you get an in-ground pool which is
yeah you can't get a raft from cvs blow
it up and then point a gun at somebody
listen if you still gotta if you got an
above ground pole i'll give you a pass
yeah in ground if he had an above ground
pool and raised up a gun i would duck i
was like yeah yeah and in tax if you
have an intex forget it no an index
you've never seen an intex spool oh
that's the only one that you just like
put up yourself real quick yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i mean
forget it i wouldn't even go near them i
wouldn't even look them in the eye now i
mean the problem is with this
unfortunately my little six-year-old
daughter delilah has been singing island
boys
non-stop so if she starts going and she
starts telling me that she thinks boys
like this are cute
then then it becomes a situation of what
do i do now
yeah what do i do now i mean at a
country level people believe in them
more than science yeah truthfully
honestly
pimp you depressed me please stop listen
listen if biden was smart to get the
last few remaining people hold on the
vaccines you put those two out there as
you say do it
no no no no no have them be like don't
get the vaccine
for the rest of the day now you're going
to go
[Music]
no but bird is the is kardashian isn't
he
what
isn't that kardashians
kim kardashian i think they the family
does that because my niece told me if
kim kardashian divorces kanye west and
winds up with one of the island boys
my life is complete uh who's the first
celeb gal that is gonna date one of
those guys the first celeb gal that goes
with one of the islands who do you think
well kardashian sisters are all taken
like someone like who like uh
maybe
baby
what's the name
baby bad baby maybe a bad baby
oh that would be a that would be a a
power cup another tick tock what's the
one charlie
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah she's a good
one up there
uh
addison ray how long until they fight
the logan paul brothers oh my god see
that's something
that's something i'd pay for what i
that's
the paul brothers versus the island boys
oh my god kodiak red kodiak right so
it does look like they might be at least
brothers but maybe twins no they're twin
brothers and they're saying the word on
the street is
that they're
cuban because they're from florida but
here's the thing with cubans is they're
right on the line between are you latino
are you white because it's i'm cuban
park cuban so you're right i wouldn't
drop an n no you never in my life
too
yeah yeah no i get it i get it man i get
not coming for myself cuban people i
don't like ham in my entire life on him
i don't like ham cuban you don't want
the cuban sandwich then i can't do the i
don't like him
i don't like it you don't like ham you
don't cheese huh
indepen um
i don't like uh i do like pig products
like i said i will eat bacon but i don't
like ham i don't like a cuban sandwich
unfortunately can you switch anything
out can it still be a cuban if it's not
jamon could i put something in i'll say
it won't be traditional but in this day
and age you know how it goes i could put
a chicken collar you you do your version
of it yeah you know it's cuban fusion or
something i like cuban fusion
yeah i always forget that you're cuban
yeah part my grandpa was cuban you're
not puerto rican at all i am a lot
puerto rican cuban my grandpa's cuban
and puerto rican i think and my
grandma's puerto rican god so i'm like a
little more than a quarter puerto rican
a little less than that question what's
the other one oh there's also some
canary spanish then halftime so so ital
so the main ones are italian
cuban puerto rican that that's your
three most in spanish from spain but
let's say the three biggest ones italian
i guess cuban puerto rican [ __ ] marry
kill italy cuba puerto rico okay you
have to do more on the show sure okay uh
italy cuba puerto rico i marry italy for
the food got it
i marry italy for the food now
[ __ ] or kill
i got a f of puerto rican
have to top-notch i did
[Music]
i'm gonna follow your footsteps yes no
um cause they're a part of the states
right and then cuba since they've been
annexed for a while i guess i would kill
them but honestly i i don't want to
put it you know if you're forcing me to
i'm forcing you to albaya pigs them
right away then yeah and then at least
if you do kill cuba and they are cuban
they go too which is not yeah oh you
mean wipe out all of cuban what's that
we're gotti i almost tried to go to cuba
right before trump went into office i
think right i was gonna go visit my and
then he
something happened where then we
couldn't visit as easily anymore it was
like going to be a hole to do we had to
have people with you and all these hoops
i've never been i've never been i've
never been either you cannot go now
though right i don't know i don't think
you can haven't really looked sergio
sergio chacon who works a lot with me
the great surgery cohen's got a great
podcast the dbs podcast um he went to
cuba
for like a missionary relief thing he
told me cuba was the most beautiful
place he's ever seen he said it
literally is like you're walking back in
time he said the cars the buildings the
style of clothing it stopped in 1960
yeah what are you looking at that for
what because i feel like you might see
one of those types of hats in cuba maybe
a
fedora
oh yeah yeah yeah it's just kind of one
of my things that i'm doing yeah yeah
you know i like it oh i like your hair i
know you're talking about that but now
it's styled differently and i told you
it looks it looks new age civil war
that's how i describe it right is is a
new way north
yes new age union
[Laughter]
you look like you make um you look like
you make uh
roadside trinkets to sell it with
bananas
or shaved ice
[Music]
because that's trademarked i think the
other one okay
i apologize so it's
i can't even do it though
you want to listen to the rest of these
kids song yeah a little bit more it's a
little bit it's a six minute wrap who's
going to collab with them first so we we
thought who might be the first girl to
be with them kanye kanye is the first
he's going through a lot right now i
haven't seen it what about little nausea
my collab with them he's high now he's
real hot right now he's not hot in the
streets he's so hot right now we have to
figure out where they lean on uh where
they stand on i want to say something
i've only seen a cumulative 20 seconds
of them so far i hope they win me over
me too yeah me too
i'll say this i've seen them and heard
about them now they've been a big part
of my life for about the past five days
yeah they have won me over they have one
they have won me over completely one
movement that's why i'm wearing this hat
little island shuffle shot remake of
their video me and you
are you is that are you confirming it's
probably being done already by so many
people right we'd have to get all over
that oh yeah but nobody does it like the
babes that's right that's true i like
that i like that as a slogan merch
nobody does it like the babe he doesn't
like the babes oh i love that nobody
doesn't like the baby train market clip
it clip it this is kanye's haircut
okay
it looks like um
is it like a like an abstract thing like
a lot of people are saying all the memes
are stevie wonder shaving his head
i mean
listen it's something different now now
it does if i'm being
honest it does look like if there's no
like the barber just freestyled it like
it's not supposed to be recreated just
like that it was an off the dome haircut
on the dome there you go it was uh it
looks like no it actually looks like a
like an abstract like it almost looks
like uh you ever see those like
1980s like just like they like like you
ever see those dixie cups the famous
dixie cups
that they have like that blue and purple
design like it's just you know it just
kind of looks like like a like a
painting but yeah it's a one-of-one you
see from the side it's a little rough
yeah from the side it looks like
from the side from the side
and we're just being honest and look he
this guy is a trailblazer and a
trendsetter so he's making shoes now
that look like straight up marshmallows
so you know i mean and people do it so
from the side it does look like he's
going through some stuff with it it
could be also one of those things where
he was like listen
my barber had an accident in the middle
of the hair can i need to get to my next
thing so this is not my haircut and but
all these kids now are going to go do a
haircut like this but he was like no i
immediately shaved my head as soon as i
was done
that's kanye meeting with michael cohen
there you go yesterday or two days ago
he got he got caught in a meeting with
michael cohen and that's the mask he was
wearing yeah that's very i am um that's
very very very wait wait hold on that is
kanye west i feel him back
that's on the left that is kanye west
it looks like that sketch from eddie
murphy from senate live when he goes to
the bus as a white man yeah no that is
that is kanye west right there why would
he put on a rubber michael cohen who was
michael cohen michael cohen was trump's
lawyer
recognized the name and then he left
house arrest they put him in jail and
then he's back on house arrest but he's
not allowed
he keeps violating it like he's not
supposed to go like i don't know what
let's say the exact rules like he can't
go past 71st street he many times has
been filmed at a restaurant on 68th
street just and it's like you're going
back how do you know these details
because the new york post
you know he's in the tabloids and they
went they went to preda manger together
they went somewhere with some
restaurants it's like cozy yeah it's
gotta be somewhere on the what can you
zoom in on kanye west's rubber head
could you that's kanye west he's walked
outside he should do a whole concert
like that kanye west look at him look at
me down there too he's amazing look at
him that's kind of i was at that concert
actually
i really was where do you think that is
what i went two nights in a row i sat in
the first row
when he had the stocking on his head
where was that it was i went to barclays
was it unbelievable and then there was a
barclays and i think the garden it was
two i went it was pretty amazing like
what he did he had a runway he would
walk right through the crowd we were at
the runway and then he had this amazing
like
mountain and like this whole light show
that would like come down and he had all
these like soldiers and stuff it was
really like it was really sight to see
and i'm pretty sure the reason i really
really really wanted to go too was it
was uh
it was tribe open forum wow and it was
like one of the last like oh i think
fight yes
i think five hadn't
well maybe what i don't remember was
before after five no they wouldn't have
done one without five so it was before
five passed i guess wow yeah yeah so
this is this is to remain inconspicuous
yeah and this is their like second or
third meeting together
so the idea would be how do you take not
kanye west but michael cohen is
is having lunch with the store mannequin
yeah
yeah
so so yes michael cohen it's probably
right outside the windows of macy's
herald square and then one of those real
life mannequin came to life it's like
[ __ ] mannequin in the movie so it's
like yeah it's either that's kanye west
or michael cohen is a full schizophrenic
yeah and and so but that's very very
very interesting but couldn't he have
won like um like a mask like covered
like a mask
i don't know i just think that that
calls just as much attention to him he's
a rubber head
it looks like i don't want to be around
anymore yeah yeah yeah i can't breathe i
can't breathe it's too much mask no i
don't think you should leave yeah that's
true that's funniest show in freaking a
decade
also curb starts this week i think wow
um shout out curb so he looks like also
a crash test dummy so they knew but they
must have known people knew it was kanye
because they're taking selfies with them
or you just want to take that guy
oh my god that guy ran up to his face
yeah so he didn't have security with him
he's crazy right now and then you saw he
flew economy
no no
i think i actually think it's so hard
he's such a genius right i don't know
he's he's in he's i i have so many mixed
feelings about kanye
see kanye blew economy on a regular
plane
like a week or two ago
he knows he knows
was that is that to stay in the news you
think i don't know
some really internal [ __ ] like i want to
he also you'll change his name to ye
legally yay
yay but no what princeton oh i was just
saying
that but that is the thing
i was saying
why a why well but i think kanye is a
good example of a person who you hear
this time and time again is you know
genius and insanity border very close i
think he flips both i think he i think
he dips into genius and inside can we
say that about some of the greatest
artists of all time seriously dude i
mean some of the greatest artists of all
time they need betterhelp.com
see he also looks like my dad right my
dad just put up no not my dad
my dad in his garage he just put up a
speed bag and he put up a he got that
guy that's just like a a torso and you
punch him yes and then he goes and he
comes back up he has a name he looks
like that guy that you punch to work out
with wow it's so interesting i just put
up a heavy bag in my garage did you
realize i did i just put up a boxing
heavy bag right
wow look at this we're at me and your
friends into boxing i gotta get back
into boxing because i it's it's one of
those things where i've realized i
haven't done it now in four months and i
can't explain to you how deflated and
awful my body feels and i feel like i
hit the bag today and the muscles that
like felt like puffy again started to
feel less puffy or more pun i start to
feel like a little bit better now just
from hitting the back once those little
muscles that i used to have that are
absolutely now gone and have turned into
mini cinnabons i need to get them back
through boxing it also you haven't hit
the bag in four months i have it at the
bag i want to say similar because i
haven't hit it in four to four years
four years yeah 44. yeah yeah yeah 44.
yeah
um dude so yeah man i i think kanye's
crazy but i think island boys maybe i
maybe that's what they were discussing
kanye west and michael cohen is the is
you know the island boys
yeah if kanye i mean it kanye it was
weird when he i don't know he's he's
he's so polarizing but honestly if he if
he was like i want to talk to you about
a project i would go immediately oh my
god if you want to talk to me about
anything i'd go yeah the thing is i
would be like what do you want me to do
kanye kanye west is the kind of person
like you literally here's what i
genuinely think about kanye west he
literally is i would argue one of the
top five most famous people on the whole
planet of the billions of us
i would not be shocked if
us or even you know someone higher or
lower just somebody who's you know
a podcaster could dm his personal
account and he would get back to you and
come on to the podcast yeah that's like
that kanye could do he's a wild card
he's a wild card he most likely not but
he could come onto the podcast how old
is i think we're the same age
this is a good one
liquid iv liquid iv i've been hearing
all about this dude it saved me from so
many hangovers i got
wrecked last night
i woke up the next morning and the
hangover of all hangovers was happening
to me i was like is zach galifianakis
here right now cause my head feels like
it's gonna fall off liquid iv
no no liquid iv
saved my life okay i know you can use it
for the flu and to get your vitamins up
but it was for me that my hangover just
went away because liquid iv gave me the
the i was dehydrated and this thing
hydrated me like you couldn't imagine i
ca i'm actually super excited the other
day my friend texted me before i found
out that they were gonna uh advertise
with us okay and because we went to a
concert and i had a double vodka soda
whoa came home had a little bit of a
headache don't drink much anymore and uh
had another couple glasses of wine here
it was it was a weekend night okay i
went wild yeah you went wild next day
had a headache he texted me he goes i'm
coming over home later watch football he
goes i'll bring you a liquid iv yeah i
was like liquid iv what's that this is
what it is it contains five essential
vitamins more vitamin c than an orange
and as much potassium as a banana
hydrates you faster and more efficiently
than water alone it's healthier than
sugary sports it's made with clean
ingredients it's non-gmo vegan and free
of gluten dairy and soy yep
no soy boys here and the company is
donating four million servings in
response to clovin 19 products are being
donated to hospitals first responders
food banks veterans and active military
i'm telling you liquid iv you know it
helps prevent stuff it just gets you
hydrated liquid iv is what you need i
don't actually leave the house or i have
a day where i don't drink liquid iv and
you're gonna get they got so many
flavors strawberry watermelon all
different types of beautiful flavors
you're going to get a sweet discount
right now if you go to liquidiv.com and
use hey babe at checkout
liquidiv.com code hey babe 25 off
anything you order 25 off anything you
order when you get better hydration
today using promo code hey babe at
liquidity.com yes
grab your favorite you know you can grab
your favorite liquid iv i'm thinking
walmart baby walmart is where you can
get it all the flavors and you know we
can get 25 off here here right here
liquid iv dot com use the code hey babe
at checkout 25 off anything you want
liquid iv.com promo code hey babe all
right this podcast sponsored by
betterhelp that's right you know it
better help with cis betterhelp will
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
you can start communicating with someone
in under 48 hours it's not a crisis line
no it's not self-help it is professional
counseling done securely online there's
a broad range of expertise available
which may not be locally available in
many areas services available for
clients worldwide you can log into your
account anytime i'm on it better help
and it helps me so much
yeah you can message your counselor i
mean i'm not saying but you can message
me
message him
when we say message we're assuming
you're messaging on the up and up on the
up and up i'm saying again don't get
crazy it's more affordable than
traditional off offline counseling and
financial aid is available wow that'll
help want you to start living a happier
life today visit their website and read
their
testimonials uh special offer we knew
that was coming you know special offer
for hey babe listeners get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com
hey babe that's b e t t e r h e l p dot
com slash hey did you just know how to
spell that without even looking at the
thing like you from memory you know how
to spell better and help yeah wow i
don't it wasn't easy
took years
betterhelp.com hey babe not health you
psycho there you go exact same age he's
76 77 or 75
77 june of 1977. i got him by uh nine uh
eight months
because what's your birthday again
november 6 76 november 676. he's one of
the 1776 yeah
patriot yeah got the haircut he's one of
the scariest people to be around i
photographed him once and i was
terrified like he has an energy where he
will explode on you but but but you
could also catch him when he's like
probably the nicest guy in the world
did you ever see have you ever watched
this interview no
i've heard so many funny stories
you've never actually seen sway in the
mornings what none of you i've never
seen i got the answer sway
you've never seen you ain't got the
answers maybe i have but i don't know no
this is like what made kanye well did he
turn on swag parker all on that summer
jams kind of and by the way mark raise
your boys i will still accept an
investment in donda i got some more
ideas that don't involve shoes but if
you guys are investing in the arts
y'all want to invest in this school in
brazil y'all want to go to africa i'm
standing up and i'm telling you i am
warhol
i am the number one most impactful
artist of our generation i am
shakespeare in the flesh
disney
nike google look at this sweatshirt
gonna be the medici family and stand up
and let me clean up more i love you
pause one second is this
i know he was going off on this when he
couldn't get a fashion deal but he's
like who's gonna let me do more can he
write his own ticket i'm so confused
well he wants what does he need at this
point in time he wanted to revolutionize
education and the parks
you mean what do you mean the parks
public police
like i don't know he's going on and on i
like what he's saying he wants to help
poor people have better lives oh amazing
he he did go from i'm i'm andy warhol on
walt disney and then he said i'm google
marginalize me till i'm out of my moment
or why don't you empower yourself and
don't need them and do it just i just
said that that's why you swipe a few
steps back
you ain't got the answers man you
already got the answers
you ain't got the answers you ain't got
the answer swag
i've been doing this more than you doing
you ain't got it come on you ain't got
the answers you ain't got the answers
you don't have the answers though
because you're trying to give me advice
about something you ain't you ain't got
the answer you ain't spend 13 million
dollars in your own money trying to
empower yourself but i spent hundreds of
thousands in putting out clothing lines
at a smaller degree all i'm asking you
and there ain't no ralph though
what's the name of your clothing line we
don't know
what i'm saying
ralph lauren
he's comparing his brand to ralph saying
it's nothing like ralph lauren no wreck
it
[Laughter]
machio
isis
[Laughter]
crammed
and i could lose money on a higher level
too don't think just because
i got the most
i lost the money because i did not have
the
knowledge so you don't have the money to
do it that's your answer you ain't got
to turn up man this ain't no [ __ ]
show man i'm not talking to you as a
homie and ain't no homie man because
your thing is the bottom line is man
everybody gotta turn you like
what do you mean it ain't no hold up man
we here talking about civilized people
i'm trying to understand your world
because when i go to your concert i'm
curious about what you're saying i don't
know
that's why i'm asking you the questions
well i'm explaining to you okay you
ain't got to turn up on me man it just
calms down [ __ ] these mics we could turn
all this [ __ ] off you ain't got to do
this it's cool i love you bro but you
ain't got to turn away no don't try to
embarrass us i'm not trying to embarrass
y'all what i'm trying to say to y'all is
this industry of what i'm trying to get
into ain't nobody never broke down ain't
nobody broke down we all slaves so i
ain't trying to disrespect you on your
show we all slaves are suffering
i ain't trying to respect you period let
me talk if you're gonna have me talk
we all slaves
we all slaves and y'all ain't
experiencing nothing right here but a
moment from a movie out of glory
back in the days the slaves had enough
money they could body on freedom
we all say we slaves to nike we slaves
the bands we slays the public perception
we slayed to not looking you know what
somebody gonna say after the interview
why you let kanye do that you
yeah wow dude that was that was a long
time ago that was 2013. kanye that was i
remember you ain't got the answers sway
me i sway made t-shirts i said you ain't
got the answers no he sold like um
because i
hosted a show with sway called off the
bat yes about
a month or two after this came out
but the thing is he makes a good point
like all the young rappers signed 360
deals where they own the copyright to
your name right so you have to change
your name to break the contract right
yeah so like i get it but he just wasn't
wasn't um
wasn't that a big thing like a couple of
years ago when like mace called out
diddy and uh other people were calling
out like uh it's a common practice yeah
but anyway do you guys see him on ellen
this is a good this is recent this is
this is 28 may 3rd 2018.
by the way to set this up ellen you know
they they had questions they pre
pre-shipped
and kanye just stopped responding to him
and then just went on a soliloquy
of course gotta love it shout out
soliloquy shout out soliloquy oh my god
shout out stanzas
oh yeah shout out uh
shout out
shout out haikus what else is there just
silicon a haiku is there anything else
yeah it definitely is
no this there's definitely a terrible
parable
and a fable shadow day
shout out
[Laughter]
gmail.com right now and tell us if
there's another fable other than aesop's
oh bet it yet write a hey babe fable and
send it to us we'll read it on air there
you go fabulous
all right i've gone on facebook yes yes
but now i understand why he didn't hit
me back
i understand that zuckerberg doesn't use
uh twitter yeah even though i have had
dinner with him and his wife and told
him about how i wanted to help the world
and he said he'd help me and then
like that's how it feels though you know
it's like the pursuit of happiness like
it's like you're trying to sell this
bone density machine or something you
know in that movie
i
feel that if i had more resources i
could help more people
i have ideas
that can make the humans you know
uncomfortable ellen is existence she's
like i just want to yell at my staff
period
the paparazzi whatever perception you
have
of me
she's so worried
you think he would go off on ellen like
that no way oh yeah he wouldn't you
don't got the answers ellen
you don't got the answers ellen hold on
hold on a second you don't got the
answers ellen hold on a second you got
the answers ellen
what did he just say
something he got an applause he said
like [ __ ] the paparazzi or something
good okay
okay
i'm with you in the building
[Applause]
in the building like shouting her out
i was like oh my god bold
oh my god
when you say put some dope with it
just give me one example just get what
the idea is because maybe somebody
watching will give you the money
so he just goes on and on i guess asking
somebody for money to change the world
but it's interesting because he's his
value now at least is six billion
dollars yeah i was good the next thing i
was about to say was it is odd
to
see him often
asking for money
because because i think if you google
he's like a step away from a gofundme
well
because i think as far as net worth goes
because of the success of
the shoe company and all that stuff i
think his including jay-z and beyonce if
you put jay-z beyonce and i think the
next two or three highest-paid rappers
combined he has more money than all of
them combined it's a really good
google top google it's gotta be like
what's gonna be jay-z no way you'll see
they're not even close to kanye come on
come on
thirty rippers right go go all the way
down to one
as you see
go just go all the way down see 85
million and all that stuff but if you go
down to one see drake drake's eight
eight yes so you have you have uh sean
uh so you have wow
6.6 billion i'll go up a little bit he's
six point six jay z's 1.3 go up oh my
god
900 million see they're not even close
combine them you see uh dre 780 million
so we're still not even at three billion
yet and kanye's at six
two hundred and thirty not even
kanye west
more than the top ten kanye west is
worth 25 times more than eminem yes
yes
yeah and m m's worth 230 million dollars
yes and kanye west is worth almost seven
billion yeah i guess now i don't know if
this is money in in their pockets right
right
equity says american raptor and producer
fashion designer and entrepreneur he's
now the richest rapper everything 6.6
billion
wow yeah so so kanye is is is i would
imagine is kanye richer than oprah is
kanye now the richest black met person
in in the country because i know oprah
was a yeah oh my god actually twice as
rich as oprah three times almost three
times kanye is what is kanye on the list
of just rich men like just men
nah when you start throwing them up
against a sheik i think a sheik's like
yeah yeah a quintillion or something
richest americans okay so we got 188 187
129 105 bill got it okay go to 21 more
rows click that it's got to be what's
this kanye has to be somewhere in there
well what's the lowest okay 17.4 is
leonard louder from estee lauder okay
okay
yeah but but i would imagine danny
bonaducci what no kidding
oh walmart look at that well that
walmart's pretty big um an official
wizard in new zealand loses his job how
did he lose his job he was believed to
be the world's only wizard on the
government payroll paid ten thousand
annually by the city for acts of
wizardry and other wisdom-like services
no
kane should hire him
he's him he should do island boy
i island
island
listen if new zealand wasn't under
lockdown right now if they were under a
lot not under lock and key i would
invite the wizards to come to hey babe i
would love to
really he even dresses like a wizard and
has a staff yeah a nice staff too wow
like that's like that's a professional
wizard stamp so why the
one random asian guy in that photo is
fun the government believed believes in
at least partially believes in wizardry
10 000 annual contract go poof last week
he had the contract since 98.
so he's made hundreds of thousands of
dollars being a wizard he's 88 years old
ian brackenbury chanel
wow channel
wow interesting did i show you my ring
[Laughter]
with him and i was like i'm gonna get
you in
me right now stupid
it's like it actually hit me directly
i'm so sorry it's like a buck it brings
me so much joy
he just crazy
it went right in your retina
i'm sorry bro i'm sorry you just got
assassinated oh well this has been angry
draftkings baby i use it i love it
sports are back in a big way the crowds
are back it's for real sports you know
me you know i love draft kings you know
i love playing fantasy hoops you know i
played basketball division three
all-star and now i got side fat i for
the first time in my life have love
handles and i don't want to lose them
okay i have just fat i have cellulite
around my belly button but i used to be
a division three basketball player and
so i love basketball i love
playing fantasy hoops do you want a free
shot at a million dollars let me ask you
do you want a free shot at a million
dollars answer yourself yes you do yes
you do well draftkings is going to give
you that they are safe secure and
reliable best of all you can deposit and
withdraw your cash whenever you want
which is awesome i love that draftkings
does that if you download the draftkings
app right now and use the promo code hey
babe this week new customers get a free
shot at millions of dollars in total
prizes enter the promo code hey babe get
a free shot at millions of total prizes
with your first deposit that's code hey
babe only at draftkings minimum five
dollar deposit required eligibility
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
for details yeah
dude
let me me and sal
took this thing called beam organics
it's a cbd
type sleep aid powder
i had the best sleep i'm not lying to
you and sal the same that's why sal's
not hearing now he's asleep he's been
he's rumpelstiltskin he's been asleep
for 100 years because of beam organics
i've had the best sleep i've ever had i
literally slept to an emergency with my
kids which is a little dangerous but it
was great because i woke up feeling so
refreshed while my family was panicking
i felt great i hopped out of bed and i
did the elliptical for eight minutes and
then i had a boston cream
dream beam organic dream powder first of
all
it's comforting sleep promoting hot cup
of cocoa it's cocoa so it's literally
who doesn't love hot cups of cocoa
even after an isis beheading they'll sit
down and have a hot cup of cocoa
especially now during the holidays you
want this you love cocoa anyway it might
as well put you to sleep okay how well
did you sleep how well did you function
the next day how great did it taste
these are questions you'll all answer
after you take some beam organics hot
cocoa there's no thc and it's triple lab
taste tested with no added sugar or
artificial sweeteners okay none of that
baby none of that the only thing that's
going to be sweet is the way you slept
you're going to wake up with a rock
heart i promise you or if you're a woman
um i don't know what is the equivalent
of morning wood in women
rock hard nipples people are absolutely
obsessed with dream in the reviews matt
g who normally is a piece of [ __ ] but
this one actually is a good review said
tastes great gets me feeling ready for
sleep and allows me to get a great
night's sleep so that it will recover
better great stuff and if i happen to
forget to drink it i can definitely tell
the difference melanie wrote this stuff
is legit i'm a gym rat who just turned
50 and has sleep issues i take this take
this at 10 p.m and sleep from 11 to 6.
the best part is that i wake up
refreshing ready to hit the gym wow i
guarantee you melanie has fakes and i
like that
everyone needs this if you subscribe now
you'll get 35 off 35
off your first month of dream plus a
free mug and frother head to
bmorganics.com
hey babe that's b e a m organics.com hey
babe h-e-y-b-a-b-e for 35 off your first
month of your dream subscription plus
you can pause or cancel any time get
beam go to sleep
oh my god that hit me right now i did
not mean that i'm sweating around have
you been wearing that the entire show i
slipped it on about a moment ago
yeah i'm i'm i'm i'm dying here
i totally did not mean to hit you in the
eye
right now
we could get that on all right
dude this i just get hit in the face on
all my podcasts
wow
wow all right
what was that water yeah
it was breast milk it was cologne
bubbas
wow
um beverly hills is getting more and
more violent as armed robberies continue
yeah everyone's getting robbed nowadays
what can you do it's going to happen in
bev hills though yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah wow who they robbing over there
dude speaking of robbing
i got a dental cleaning the other day
yeah
first of all
i have never in my life been in more
pain
than i when i got a dental cleaning
which i said to the dentist i said is
that bad he said it's very very bad
the second he put the scalpel thing on
my tooth riveting in pain i was i was
like this where like i he was like i was
like are you done yet he goes we haven't
even put the air in yet i was like okay
okay okay okay okay i was like i was
like i can't do this and then he was
like let me at least just try to clean
one side of your mouth
you have so much plaque build up
but maybe do you have soft teeth is that
a thing i make that up my teeth are soft
as [ __ ] really yes
soft teeth
i got soft he said he said i'm i said
i'm hard in other in other areas he was
like he was like you hard but your teeth
are soft and he said i have to stop
using such a hard toothbrush i got to go
soft brushed but sal i'm telling you
dude the the the the cleanings usually
don't hurt no but that's what i said i
said i got and he found four cavities
one he told me one of my fillings that i
got from like in like 1997 he said it's
cracked wide open he said you're filling
he said you have pain in your back tooth
i said a lot you know what he did too
you know what happened you know what
happened you know what happened you know
what happened he was he he was checking
and i don't know why he had to do this i
don't know why i had to do this i don't
know why i had to do this he he took
x-rays of my teeth i'm closing my eyes
because my eyeball hurts um oh no i'm
kidding i'm kidding
he he he he took um
he took uh x-rays of my teeth and then
he said i'm not sure if there's a cavity
in one of them i don't know if it's a
filling or a cavity and he took his
little scalpel
thing and he went back and he poked out
and put the scalpel in the hole in my
teeth and i'm telling him right on the
nerve right on the nerve and i'm telling
you the pain like if you could if you
could if you if pimp could get a camera
in my butthole right now yeah it is
closed yeah tight it is the board is
coming out or going in no it cannot no
one can enter or no it's it's locked
covered lockdown yeah the pain i was
saying
and like my leg i like my leg
but i
i've never heard your voice that high
that's what happened and the dentist
laughed and he giggled no i swear i
would laugh i mean you just sounded like
literally yeah then he put his hand on
my shoulders okay it's okay it's okay he
said let me give you some numbing you
yelped you had to yelp yeah i yelled
yeah i helped and and i got he gave me
some numbing cream which is like numbing
toothpaste and he went there to gap he's
like let me just clean one side oh i put
that thing on i was like i can't i can't
i can't and i i
out of my mouth moved it down so i
jenna's hand out of my mouth yeah i said
you're gonna have to sedate me i can't
do this yes yes yes i said okay and they
said
now let me know like shooting pain
shooting am i getting ripped off what do
we think if anyone's a dentist or a
hygienist
back at home am i getting ripped off he
told me or just have interest in teeth
anybody who has knowledge if you're a
tooth guy um if if if you if if if he
told me my insurance
will not cover the deep cleaning that i
need to get because you you insurance
will only cover deep cleanings if you
have
all these issues with your teeth they
won't cover it if you just can't take
the pain of a cleaning so it's like the
insurance company won't cover it just
because i was like basically like i'm
like a [ __ ] and they were like yeah the
insurance company will not they just put
in the field whatever that you need to
put in for you that's what i said i
gotta put in [ __ ] full charge
i mean
service line like hit one hello yeah hi
it's your health insurance line you're
like i'm just calling to challenge a
bill i got in the mail because it was a
routine cleaning and you hear like
typing on the thing
she's like i see let me pull up your
file no sir i'm sorry here it says here
you're a huge [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i said to them i said to them how many
times a week do you have someone walk
out of a cleaning and he was like
i would say maybe twice a year i was
like wow i was like so i'm one of the
two and he goes yeah he goes usually
people can tolerate he goes but listen
you have a lot of plaque buildup because
i see why you don't come to the dentist
so i think the solution for you is every
time you get a cleaning let's shoot up
your mouth let's shoot up the club in
your mouth numb your entire mouth and
face and then we'll get
wow you're used to a lot of plaques you
you played a lot of ball basketball
i got a lot of plaques yeah 100 a lot of
plaques i got yeah once have you been in
the dentist oh man it's been a while it
has been a while right yeah yeah uh just
go for routine cleanings but i haven't
had anything major done recently nothing
at all
fillings
anything nothing major you know what
else you told me to me i might have
periodontal disease where they may have
to give me a gum graph which this should
be fun for the podcast he said we can
either take skin off the roof of your
mouth and then attach it to a piece of
your gum and then in in the place where
your gums are receding you know patch it
up there and we put he's this exact
quote he said we put little stitches
that kind of feel like shoelaces in your
mouth and it takes about 10 to 15 days
to fall out or we can give you cadaver
gum meaning a gum of a dead person that
we can sew into your mouth so your gums
don't because it looks like in certain
parts of my mouth my tooth is coming out
of my head
dude the gums are receding
the gums are real you've never heard of
any of this until this trip to the
dentist this was the trip to the dentist
i got hit with the gum grabs what
happened in the last couple of years
since you've been to the dentist i think
you do have to take care of these things
though because i think i don't think you
want to be messing with these things
when you get older because when you get
older it's i think it's bad it's like
way more painful i think it's bad i
think you got to fix that stuff now have
you ever heard of a gum graph never
no dude when he said gum graph he said i
think there's a gumologist
that is
he was like oh you could see our gum
specialist wow is it a gum i'll just
some people say periodontal comes i say
gummologist you know i uh when i floss
my teeth bleed and i say that's because
you don't floss enough
and i go all right well i'll start to
floss more and i got a water pick too
and i use the water pick and when i use
the water pick sometimes where sometimes
wherever i hit my teeth my gums bleed
right and i keep telling them like i i
do all this stuff you said it's supposed
to stop bleeding it always bleeds and
they're like yeah you might have bit big
gum issues like when you get older like
your teeth may just fall out but i don't
have i don't have any any
my first cavities of my entire life were
like like a year ago really yeah i got
like two or three and they
every time you go to the dentist this is
a routine cleaning in and out my whole
life i was so disappointed that i got a
cavity i never had one my whole life let
me i think sal's ready to learn about
what the amish do with the dentist what
the amish do with the dentist is to this
is a true fact that we learned on my
other podcast the christie chaos podcast
this is just a fact this is what it is
to avoid problems like you're going
through now what they what their
solution is is they just remove your
teeth
when you're in your 20s you just get
your teeth pulled and you just go with a
fake set so we don't have to worry about
cavities nothing they pull your teeth
preemptively pull them all out like
young people have dentures that's why
they do it they said you know what what
the what the best thing to do is take
every tooth in your head out of your
head oh my god
and then they just completely 100 and
then you just go for the rest of your
life with dentures on which does solve
the problem i don't know how people [ __ ]
with their teeth like that
i wouldn't do stuff to my teeth like
that i wouldn't touch anything on my
teeth no i wouldn't do anything no dude
my teeth it's bad and um yeah dude
that's why all amish people just have
great teeth great teeth
yeah because they're yeah they're fakes
well are we going back to look i found
maybe we'll end with this but i found
their vlog
okay i found the uh
daily vlog lady
okay
well there we go gang oh theo von fans
oh my god
it looks like a wig from party city
you see the line right here oh we're in
kfc man
especially sides because i love the
stars in kfc
what's it called wearing kfc
y'all want me to keep making videos like
this like uh vlogs and stuff y'all [ __ ]
with the day in life man y'all gonna see
the vibes man it's great to make music
in the mic man
y'all gonna get like a real good glimpse
of scenes of music being made man real
gulp [ __ ] man
real goat [ __ ]
oh there you go
zoom in on the nuggets oh [ __ ] goat [ __ ]
they cut to chicken tenders
which is just brother just making music
you're already the greatest of all time
greatest of all time just like going
just just booking the studio for an hour
dude it's so funny that if you want to
be in their crew you have to get their
haircut that's the only way what do you
say to the barber once you sit
do you say
do you say give me the island boy yeah
give me the island boy give me the
krusty clown but they they yeah cause
but but they are the island boys so what
did they say the first time they sat
down i mean they said yeah they said i
wanted my hair to look like the corona
virus
[Laughter]
he just sings full adele right now
trust me it's good
i don't know where his brother is though
did he kill his brother
probably working at target
yeah
[Laughter]
he's a hot topic regional manager
his baby pictures i want to see what he
looks like
his first haircut like first day of
school he saw no chalkboard that says
kindergarten first day
i'd respect it oh who's this [ __ ]
piece there's another another friend
with the hair
even his director
[Music]
yeah
i think they're going for um i think
they're going for a jay-z look who's was
going for like a basquiat look right
maybe something like that something like
that
wow nice jesus piece yeah
jesus peace almost like a full-size
jesus right there i know i made
communion i was gonna say i looked
[Laughter]
i think i think chet hanks is jealous of
them oh yeah hank's wishes your move
chat
your move
they're like we out here we are in santa
monica we out here we out here outside
of athleta big things
[Laughter]
we out here outside the dipping dots
i really hope this is what chris's
stepson turns into oh my god they're
amazing that would be amazing and then i
have to finance the whole thing
we out here doing real gangster [ __ ]
outside the sunglass hut yo oh we have
the coffee bean
we out here outside uh delia's bro
dude i would love for these guys to have
beef with us oh my god
beef with the hay bay podcast impossible
this is in celebration of you fellas in
celebration yeah i'll do a music video
any time you want to yeah
oh no what is that he's in a hazmat suit
i legitimately and i i mean this if for
some reason
if you're listening island boys and we
know that you are if for some reason
this gets to them truthfully i mean you
guys are putting yourself out there and
you are peculiar people and we are
celebrating that and you might be like
oh [ __ ] these guys or whatever but truly
and honestly i would sit down with the
two of them and have a freaking
three-hour podcast and talk to him about
everything really get to know him i
would love that i want to say this right
now i want to say shout out the island
boys shout out tom brady for winning
that damn super bowl he did it again in
tampa
on the tampa bay buccaneers age 43
amazing and i'd be remiss finally
mentioned patrick mahomes great great
great player for the kansas city chiefs
and we're coming to missouri that's
right we're going to be at st louis st
louis december
29th 29th at the factory babes and we're
also going to be december 26th
27th 28th in texas yes then december
29th at the factory december 30th
columbus ohio new york 31st new year's
eve also known as new year's steve
cincinnati ohio tickets available on
both our websites right now and october
26 in durham october 29th of durham
start what it is october 29th that's
what it is it's coming up
durham is you better be going a dorm
tomorrow 100 forums tomorrow baby
tomorrow and we got solo dates check
those out too
check them out
christiecomedy.comcomedy.com it's been
hey babe it's been hey babe hey chris
and sally are they island babies hey i
said chris and you're island babies
without them boys you stop already
playing